when i was 18 years old everything i
knew about paying for college
could have fit on the postage stamp that
came on my acceptance letter
going to college can be a gold mine the
average college graduate makes about a
million dollars more over their lifetime
than someone without a degree
but the overall profitability of your
degree depends greatly on
how you pay for it the path to hitting
the mother lode can be strewn with
twists
turns and dead ends but if you're
willing to put in the work
there's actually a lot of gold in them
thar hills
[Music]
seventy percent of college students
don't have their education costs fully
covered by family
so prospecting for financial aid is a
new student's
most important first step but where to
begin with the ultimate financial aid
treasure map
the free application for student aid or
fafsa
it's 108 questions that dig into your
personal and financial history
it's your best shot for obtaining the
most amount of free or
low-cost college aid out there
surprisingly only 61 percent of high
school students are filling it out
yes it might look intimidating at first
but most people report that completing
the entire forum
only takes about an hour it can be sent
to 10 schools at once
and you can do it before you even apply
to college there's even a handy website
that lists common mistakes to avoid when
completing the fafsa
and hey now that you're a legal adult
you may as well get used to filling out
tedious forms each school will send you
an award letter with different offers
you'll need to sift through the sediment
to find what treasure may lie beneath
the surface
the real painter you're hoping for is
free money
aka grants and scholarships these might
come from the federal government
the state or the school itself the
amount you're offered can be need-based
or
merit-based so having a low family
income or high grades will help your
chances but
contrary to popular belief there is no
income cut off when it comes to aid
so don't let that stop you from
prospecting over
13 million students receive financial
aid every year
so how can you get a leg up in this gold
rush first
file early gift aid is first come first
served
if you wait too long to stake a claim
you could find the vein has been bled
dry
fafsa forms become available the 1st of
october and you'll have to redo it every
year so
put an ongoing reminder in your calendar
if you're still a dependent
most of the fafsa information will be
based on your parents finances
if you happen to go back and forth
between guardians households
spending more time with the lower
earning parent could make you eligible
for more needs-based aid
or if one parent has children already in
college claiming
them as the custodial parent could also
end up putting more money in your pocket
and finally you can appeal the letter if
you don't love the outcome
try calling their financial aid
department and explaining your situation
you can even show them award letters for
colleges that are offering you more
you might have more leverage than you
think your award letter will let you
know whether you're eligible to take
part in a work study program
in 2019 only 14 percent of students took
advantage of jobs
offered through their university you'll
probably only make a few thousand
dollars during the academic year
but the perks can be sweet working on
campus you won't have to commute
your hours are always scheduled around
your classes and some
even allow you to do homework on the job
most importantly
you could get a head start on your
career by getting work experience in
your chosen field
while you're still in school now i know
the idea of cobbling together a free
ride
is super appealing but it might be time
for a little reality check
according to a study done back in 2016
only
18.8 percent of undergraduate students
received enough
gift aid to cover half the cost of
attendance
so unless you can make up the difference
with
savings or working attend you might have
to prepare yourself to join the
70 of your fellow graduates in taking on
some student loans
and it's important to learn that not all
of them are created
equal federal student loans typically
have the most favorable terms
and depending on your fafsa can even be
subsidized which means the government
actually pays the interest while you're
in school and sometimes even afterwards
even unsubsidized federal student loans
have advantages
you don't have to pay while you're still
in school and once you're out
some will allow you to adjust your
payment schedule based on your income so
it never gets too onerous
if you end up working in certain fields
like teaching or
healthcare in underserved areas your
federal loans could be eligible
for forgiveness the last type of aid is
private student loans
they can seem attractive at first
because you don't have to bother with
the fafsa
but you will have to show credit
worthiness and ability to pay back the
loan
since this is tough for young folks you
might have to get a family member to
co-sign for these
the terms and conditions are set by the
lender rather than the government
and interest rates are typically higher
federal loans are currently offered
around 4.5
while the average private fixed rate
loan starts around 6.17
that might not sound like a huge spread
but with the average student debt load
hovering around 31 grand
and taking 21 years to pay off those
couple percentage points could mean 7
in interest alone some private student
loans can go as high as
14 too afraid to do the math on that one
but this is starting to feel more like
fool's gold to me
as you can see there are a lot of
different paths to tread when it comes
to paying for college
and i think it's a pretty good parallel
to life in general
truly valuable things are usually hidden
behind a lot of hard work and sacrifice
whereas easier paths come with a lot of
strings attached
but remember even if you end up having
to take out loans
it's not the end of the world any degree
even a 100
financed one is better than none at all
and that's our two cents
having a rough year you're not alone
we're all trying to make sense of 2020.
that's why we think you should check out
self-evident a new show
hosted by our friends daniel bainbridge
from the origin of everything
and ali mathew from the psych show
because who better than a historian
and a therapist to help guide us through
this very weird year
link in our description hey before you
go pbs digital studios and two cents
wants to hear
from you we do a survey every year that
helps us make more of the stuff
you want to see you even get to vote on
potential new shows
take the survey at the link in the
description and let them know
two cents is your favorite
you